and our next guest is a talented actress
you know from hit shows like crazy
ex-girlfriend
you can also catch her on the complete
first season of mr mayer which is now
streaming on peacock
check it out statistically we should be
married by age 29.5 and i'll need at
least a year for my mom to lose the
weight what are you saying tommy
we are going to meet our spouses in this
building no
here
the pool is too small i don't want to be
a stepmom to a possum
it's a sugar glider idiot how are we
supposed to meet anyone here
[Applause]
please
[Music]
thank you so much look beautiful i wish
i were as tall as you as well okay no
no i really do i'm 5'3 it's nice to meet
you so nice to meet you
that was hilarious the clip is just such
a fun cast to work with it's so much fun
yeah it's crazy i i have to pinch myself
all the time because i'm like
it feels like tv royalty that i get to
work and yeah i feel like you just laugh
on set probably all day long yeah all
the time i'm always the first person to
break too
i'm always like i keep it together oh my
gosh
i'm not good at that yeah and i was like
how am i supposed to not laugh right now
that's not like once they're trying to
make you laugh
yeah yeah these are funny yes i i heard
something about you though that
we have a similarity my mom was single
for for quite some time too and a
teacher yeah you grew up with this thing
i know
it made me feel so i was like oh kelly
gets it yeah
yeah well i get being poor um because
teachers make no money
yes exactly yeah teachers more and you
watch your mom just
kill it my mom was such a hard worker
yeah and like doing a million things at
the same time multi-tasking you also
like never get away with anything
because there's no there's no one to be
like well that parent said
no but what about that parent yeah my
mom was like no as i know
so where did you grow up um i grew up in
santa fe new mexico mostly
yeah yeah it's it's a pretty weird town
i have to say like i love it i visited
have you really yeah oh amazing
yeah what did you do i was there because
a friend was shooting something and
um and and i was there and for that
reason well what's so crazy is when i
was growing
up i was like i have to get out of here
which now i'm like maybe that's more
about
teenagers than actually about 100
but um yeah i was like i have to get to
the big city but now like all of these
film projects are filming in new mexico
and i'm like this is so
wild like my pe teacher is like works in
the film industry now
i'm like well that's cool yeah yeah yeah
it's happening it's like it's a big it's
a big thing there now
it is funny though how we want to escape
from and then and then all of a sudden
like all i crave is a small town
yeah like totally i love a small i know
i love going back home
and like it's it has a totally like kind
of eclectic art scene and
george rr martin who wrote game of
thrones he lives in santa fe which kind
of gives you an insight
to like and the shopping is awesome you
have such cool stores like antiques
turquoise yeah i love turquoise yeah
yeah yeah
um well don't they have a crazy you like
said the art scene were you always into
that like when you're a kid
yeah we're always artistic yeah
definitely like i definitely grew up and
um wanted to like loved being in plays
and um i played piano when i was young i
thought i was gonna be like a concert
pianist oh you were good
yeah well my mom i think when i was
little um noticed i had like a lot
of nervous energy with my hands and was
like um my grandparents have a piano so
we're just gonna put her in piano
lessons
yeah i thought i was gonna be like a
classical pianist until i was like um
until i went to college
and then i kind of discovered acting and
realized all right
life choices life choices yeah and i
feel like you your mind kind of
um like you kind of have weird goggles
in new york where you're like i'm
sharing a one bedroom with eight people
but it's amazing
like you're just like this is such a
great deal and i like
i shower in the sink but it's so so fun
yeah yeah well congrats on season two of
mr mayor this is awesome
thank you so much for everybody that
hasn't seen it can you say who you play
yes so i play um michaela and i am a ted
danson's chief of staff
so dream role um and
uh yeah ted danson plays the mayor of la
who like unexpectedly
won to impress his teenage daughter and
i play
i was his campaign manager during the
campaign and then all of a sudden
he makes me his chief of staff so like
michaela is completely out of her depth
she's like never worked in public office
before and she's
running the whole administration so it's
a really fun
terrifying yeah it's terrifying yeah
totally she it's it's a fun character to
play though because i feel like she's
just posing and she's like i know what
i'm doing but i have no idea what i'm
doing yeah so
but i am going to blow my way through
yes i'm going to fake it until somebody
notices because that's all we do exactly
yeah that's what life is right
um well everybody the complete first
season of mr mayor is now available to
stream on peacock you gotta check it out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
[Music]